Howard is now the co-founder and CEO of
Rome he is the former uh co-founder and
CEO of yext which uh he took public here
in New York City
um and we're going to talk about hacks
tricks tips of a repeat founder many of
the things we're going to talk about
today I think go against conventional
wisdom or what many people would say is
common sense so first
mentality wise is where I want to start
you start the first one eat glass for a
while it works you take it public you
get to like raise the trophy ring the
bell you win
why the are you doing it again
[Applause]
I'm obviously got a sickness uh
Rome to the next day after I step back
from next I refer to the company so
I think it really now it's interesting
because when you think about the energy
that you use as your company grows
there's different phases of every
company so you know kind of going from
zero to one is very different than
running a global public company at scale
so the actions you have to take change
over that time so while I may have
depleted all of my sort of stamina
around how to talk to Public Market
hedge funds about EPS last quarter I had
a lot of energy reserves built up for a
zero to one type of uh Innovation period
so it was not that hard to kind of just
shift given that I had a lot left to do
this but yeah I'm crazy
um some of the things we're going to
talk about today are not just theories
you have you're actively doing it as you
build Rome
um and so one of the things that you did
which I think surprised people very
quickly uh is you named one of our
mutual friends Brent Saunders as the
chairman of the board you are a startup
having a board sometimes is even unique
for a startup but the founder not being
the chairman of the board I think is
very rare why did you do that so this is
one of my first hacks and I'm actually
kind of shocked that more people don't
do this
when you are starting a company you have
maximum leverage to do whatever you want
in particularly construct your board and
board construction isn't really
something that you think about until
later on but what you want to be doing
as much as possible when you start your
company is stacking the board of
directors we're talking about the board
of directors here I assume everybody
knows what the board of directors is you
want to
stack that in your favor as much as
possible early on because the decisions
that you make on day one like stay with
you forever it's kind of like if you
write something in your corporate
charter even when you go to raise an A
and A B and A C in further rounds it
tends to not change these these things
tend to stick and so for example if you
have two co-founders and you put all
three of you on the board like when you
go to raise an a round or a B round
usually somebody's not going to say oh
you have to kick someone off the board
so all of a sudden if you're thinking
about should I put two people on my
board or three people now you have three
board seats instead of two so you
basically stacked the board deck in your
favorite out of the get-go now there's
you can sort of take this to the next
level and every board has a chairman and
the chairman is simply it can be
interpreted however you want
operationally but the chairman is
actually really just a ceremonial title
they don't really do anything uh they
literally have one function which is to
call the meeting to order
so it's like kind of like you guys up
here just calling the conference to
order for the day they stand up here
they do it and then like the chairman
can do whatever they want the chair so
as you're the earlier you are the more
likely you are going to be able to sort
of set this up in your favor and so I
named like you said Brent Saunders the
chairman of Rome and why would I do that
I mean look I've run a public company
I've done billion dollar IPOs I've
raised half a billion dollars of capital
why do I need somebody to kind of like
go along this and the fact is that it
doesn't matter where you are there's
always someone that has done more
than you and Brent is the perfect
example of that because Brent ran and
was was the CEO and chairman of allergen
Health which is an 84 billion 83 billion
dollar pharmaceutical company and so you
know you can kind of keep leveling up
and you're really just the function of
the people around you as much as
possible so I just wanted to you know
since since my objective this time
around with Rome is to go to that level
of scale I wanted someone that had kind
of Chartered those past before but the
coolest thing is if you put if you have
a Visa now let's say you're you're not
incubated but like you have a series a
investor and they're a venture
capitalist and you go to that VC and say
look you know I think we should I'd like
to find someone better and smarter than
me to be the chairman of the company and
by the way this person is the founder of
the CEO of a 50 billion or 10 billion
dollar Fortune 50 company people the VC
will say yes to that like it's a it's a
it's a really good signal for your
company if you can get somebody that's
been on public boards and has been the
CEO of something to join your board it's
a huge signal of strength to investors
it's a huge signal of strength to
customers that somebody of that caliber
is willing to to take it on and frankly
a lot of these people that have done
these kinds of things before are like
open-minded to being like the chairman
of a startup they think it's cool like
I've seen this happen before
um so you know sprinkler for example has
as a chairman that was like a very high
level executive at Cisco so I just I
think it's a really good uh technique to
first off stack the board in your favor
second give someone get someone in there
in the room that really can just do a
totally different thing than you're able
to do since you're trying to go from
zero to one and they may have done
something way bigger uh and then and
then third really set yourself up for
the long run in having a board
construction that's going to be to your
favor
you do five-minute meetings
Teddy Roosevelt did five minutes and
Howard Lerman
let me say it like this
uh why do you do the five minute
meetings by the way I like sometimes
just wish I like could ride in here like
on a horse
like a Rough Rider
Teddy Roosevelt used to do these
five-minute meetings have you read the
bully pulpit we talked about yes yeah
the bullied Pulpit by dirt you know
Doris Kearns Goodwin she's one of my
favorite authors presidential historian
uh you know she's written the the book
about Lincoln and all that kind of stuff
but this this particular book about
about Teddy I was reading and it turned
out that Teddy Roosevelt one of the most
remarkable people you can imagine did
meetings in five minutes now we all
scheduled 30-minute meetings and 60
Minute meetings in 45 minute meetings to
talk about that's way less
important than the president used to
decide in five minutes so I'm like
reading this and I'm like my goodness
why do I need 45 minutes for a you know
certain type of design review or
whatever when the president United
States would probably make you know have
a five minute meeting and make decisions
about this and so I actually at Yaks
instituted five-minute meetings and I
think you you have to be intentional
with how you use them but the way that I
started to do these five-minute meetings
was for example when we began to expand
to Europe and we had 100 people in 120
people in London 100 people and I was
able to meet with basically all of them
in a day all 100 people in one day and
what we would do is set up five-minute
meetings and here's how it works and the
key pump is you have to be really
intentional and prescriptive and run it
by the clock so I would put a clock
there I'd have someone you know knock on
the door when 30 seconds was left so
that you had a good feeling of the time
and then I would simply ask what are you
working on
and when you ask someone what they're
and then this is pretty important I I
can be a little intense so I would not
make eye contact with the person while
they answered I I never take notes do
you take notes by the way no yeah I
never take notes either but I would
pretend to take notes because it was a
good sort of decoy into not making eye
contact with them because I didn't want
to scare the out of them so
you you begin to absorb they begin to
talk and you'd be shocked how long five
minutes is if you once you begin to
really uh get someone going
Super Bowl ad is 30 seconds so you get
like 10 ads in a row basically in five
minutes and
if you listen to them and hear them you
can absorb a ton so I would do like you
know 80 meetings in a day it's 400
minutes it actually went by pretty fast
I had a giant pile of notes when I was
done that I discarded but I I left that
with a very clear sense of everything
going on and the company would love it
because I would get to meet everybody
that was in the London office and they
would get five minutes with the CEO to
tell them what was on their mind and I
would simply ask tell me what's on your
mind tell me what tell me what you're
working on and frankly a lot of times
people would get it out and then it
would be over and then they'd End early
just you know the more intelligent
people are the more they begin to do
higher level chunking with Concepts you
know exactly what I'm talking about
because that's how the human brain works
it's like the fox and the you know it's
like sour grapes that term comes from
you know the story The Fable of the
famished Fox that was looking at them
and couldn't get them and then decided
well I didn't want those groups
anyway I couldn't get them so sour
grapes is a term that we all understand
and so people that are working together
closely and are highly intelligent and
working towards the shared Mission are
able to begin to chunk at higher levels
and do and and convey faster Concepts to
each other which means you need less
time to actually communicate
you make a lot of people the founder we
heard yesterday advice that maybe there
should be like one founder and if you
bring on a second or third founder it's
kind of later in smaller Equity you take
a different tact which is a classic it
depends type and answer why do you make
so many people the founder of the
company it's interesting because being a
founder or not is actually kind of like
a random point in time and you know you
all are founders you may have people
that are co-founders that may had they
come with you a year later or two years
later they wouldn't technically be
Founders sort of being a founder or not
is clearly there's one that there's the
founder that makes stuff like the whole
thing happen or a couple people that
make it happen but then there might be
some other people that are around you at
that exact point in time and if there
are other people that are around you at
that exact point in time
this gets to my next sort of cheat code
or hack which is to make them a founder
and give them Founders equity
this is a little bit of an
unconventional stance in Rome we have I
believe 18 people that are technically
Founders in the cap table
the wealth creation opportunity for
someone who is a Founder versus not a
Founder is Stark and I actually don't
you have to use them but I don't really
love stock options as a compensation
tool because I think they're first off
nobody knows how to Value them properly
everybody values them differently so you
could offer the same stock options
package to somebody another person and
they they literally have no idea how to
how to how to Value it the tax treatment
is absolutely terrible you get
short-term tax treatment on on stock
options uh so that and that has no
bearing on like what the sort of person
here contributed or not so
by making someone a co-founder uh or a
Founder out of the gate and giving them
Founders Equity one of the main things
they actually get right away is qsvx tax
treatment which means that their first
10 million dollars are tax-free from the
from the feds if you're not in
California uh and so this is just like a
a windfall uh and if you have an outside
success for your company it actually
actually and if if you ever get
about this from like a VC or something
where they're like why would you make
all these people Founders blah blah blah
you're giving up too much stock if they
get better tax treatment from the qsbs
thing and can save up to 10 million tax
free you can give less shares that will
be worth more money
and
create this win-win where the person
gets long-term treatment qsbs and
you don't have to give out as many
shares to give them the same amount of
value that they otherwise would have had
so it just seems like a pretty
no-brainer kind of thing to do and you
can still have the stock vest and and
and take it away if you fire them or
they leave they you know the investing
can happen in a traditional way in the
same way that stock options vest just
the tax treatment so much better but
then there's also the matter of pride
and if you let someone go around let
someone if someone can go around and say
that they're a founder of something uh
it really changes their conviction level
it changes their contribution level and
they're in the trenches with you and and
along with you for the ride so I
recommend if you can bring people along
for that ride as many people that are
going to be along for that ride and make
him a founder
you host a lot of events
um but you have this idea of Hosting
customer dinners for VIPs this is
another trick I was actually talking to
a Founder so about three weeks ago I
went to saster you guys know saster the
Jason limkins conference not as good as
this obviously
um and it's really focused on I paid him
to say that
free stage time it's a
for SAS you know SAS Focus companies and
there's it's kind of got like the dream
Force type thing it's like the
anti-sales force anti-dream force kind
of conference in San Francisco and we
had a dinner we hosted a dinner on uh
Wednesday you know one of the Wednesday
nights there uh and there was another
founder who I invited to the dinner and
she's the founder of a great startup
here in New York and they're doing
awesome their B series probably 15
million of AR maybe a little less but
growing pretty nicely and she's like I'm
sorry I can't come we're hosting our own
dinner and
we and I talked to her the next day and
I was like well how'd your dinner go
she's like actually like we had a lot of
trouble getting people to come it was
like people didn't show and she's like
well how did your dinner go well here's
what we did
you guys know Scott belski who's the
head of Adobe Creative Cloud so I saw he
was a speaker at the conference
so I read I like Ping Scott I was like
Scott can I host a VIP dinner in your
honor
at Nobu
he was like well I guess I'm gonna be in
town I knew he was from New York and he
so he's like what's he gonna do that of
course so he's not gonna have anything
to do so I was Scott's like sure so then
I just started emailing Founders like
hey I'm hosting a VIP dinner for Scott
belski you want to come and meet Scott
belski so I just hijacked his name and
got 32 people to show up to Nobu that
all came and we had a really high
response rate
so you should do that that's a really
good trick as opposed to hey come to my
you know startups dinner it's going to
be really cool and I'm going to you know
promote my product and sell my product
and by the way he was absolutely
brilliant he the the kinds of tips and
techniques and things he said were uh
that that people wanted to you know with
with the future of you know figma and
all the Adobe strategy around all that
kind of stuff I mean he's the one that
spearheaded that acquisition so people
that use I mean how many of you use
figma in the last couple days like
looked at a Design Line everybody so
people were asking about that obviously
there's there's Anti-Trust issues there
but just being able to kind of hear from
a founder and a unicorn person that then
had gone on to sort of big you know to
run a big company and as a number two or
three executive at one of the world's
largest software companies is a
compelling kind of thing versus hey come
to my startups dinner it's gonna be
awesome
when you went to raise money for Rome I
think you texted me and said that you
were starting another company
uh and you wanted me to come see the
product and so I said I'm in when you
want me to come see the product you let
me put a couple little pennies into Rome
but I was surprised at how low the
valuation was when you sent the docs
because no matter what valuation you
would have picked I and many others
would have invested why do you think
keeping the valuation low so important
how many of you are concerned about
dilution
I I really think that it is incorrect I
think pretty much you're gonna I'm sorry
like you're gonna have a binary outcome
like the thing that you can actually do
is yourself if you raise a too high
of evaluation because it limits your
optionality pretty much Acquisitions in
m a really only happen at a few levels
there's kind of sub 100 million dollar
then there's like 250 to 300 then you
get to like the 800 range and then
there's the Billion Dollar Plus in which
case you've already won and it doesn't
really matter if you own eight percent
or twelve percent when you sell your
company for like 2.6 billion dollars
you're going to make kind of a lot of
money and you don't you don't really
care about it at that point and the
thing though is that a lot of people
that could get rich at that sub 100
million or even 300 million dollar level
raise money at that valuation thinking
that it makes them feel good that their
company is worth that but let me tell
you something about when you raise money
your company is not worth that number
that just means that one person has
decided that there's like a one in ten
chance that your company is going to be
worth like a lot more than that number
it doesn't mean that your stock is worth
that amount it means that there's a
probability that your stock is going to
be worth a higher number than that
amount and so the VC the venture
capitalist is clearly playing that game
it's their advantage to have you know as
many different bets as possible and when
you run all those different bets
together they end up with outcomes that
ideally are in excess of what they've
invested but in the case of you you have
a binary outcome it's either going to be
zero or one and if you raise money at
two high evaluations you preclude
yourself sometimes from lower outcomes
which could end up being highly
advantageous to you personally but not
so much your VC so my recommendation in
general is to not and I'm not trying
like I didn't do this because it now
there's another side of this too I'm not
trying to sell room rates at 90 million
95 we're not trying to to sell I
wouldn't sell for many multiples of that
right now that's not our objective
there's another reason too that you want
to maybe keep things a little bit lower
uh than you otherwise would number one
is when you issue stock options which is
an instrument which I hate clearly it
happens to the forward on a value but I
still hate that instrument it's a
necessary evil you want to keep that as
low as possible because you want your
employees that are that are with you to
be incentivized to be along for the ride
and have as much skin in the game as
possible number one number two I just
think it's better and you saw this
happen with instacart they price their
IPO a little bit lower and every was
like oh Bill Gurley they left money on
the table if I had his Texas accent by
the way
but the point is that
you know you you sort of can price it a
little lower which yes technically cost
you money but it gets you people that
are there for the long run so you know
pomp I've by by pushing by by not
maximizing valuation the first time I
now have you more aligned with me for
the long run because we're there's
nothing that that gets someone on your
team than being in the money together
you have this idea of
memorizing lines to make perfect copy
which is
something that I don't think a lot of
people think about why is that important
so John Lennon used to
when he would come up with a song
he would sing the song and he would then
put the guitar piano down
and then come back to it the next day
and if he couldn't remember the song
he would think to himself
why should some kid and listen to the
radio remember the song If the author of
the song can't remember it how will it
be memorable to the to the people
listening later on so he used that as a
standard
for whether or not a song was good
enough now none of you all have to write
music or copy as good as John Lennon or
an author or artist but it turns out
that
the mere Act of memorizing something is
an editing function and when you go out
and you memorize your lines
your brain the human brain actually kind
of has a bug which is a feature the
feature is the human brain won't
remember stuff that's not good which is
awesome if you think about it because it
means that it only remember stuff that's
really good so if you can exploit that
feature it means that you can do this
and so if you if you've got like a
speech or you've got something you want
to say I think going through the process
of memorizing it will make it probably
tighter
it will especially if you do it verbally
like if you go back to ancient times
like it used to be the orators where
like the the ultimate way to to to
communicate today we're all written
we're all reading that's not how it used
to be in fact uh I could be wrong about
this but I believe that one of the
ancient philosophers was sort of killed
because he wasn't ready to order it at
the level that he was expected to orate
you're sort of smiling because you
obviously know the story too point is
when you memorize your lines you make it
chunkier you chunk it up into these sort
of better Concepts that people can
identify with it's faster it's better
and it ends up being it's almost like a
meme
so something you and I have talked a ton
about is this idea of calendar zero and
no one-on-one meetings if someone starts
a business especially the first time
they have direct reports how do I
communicate with them what is the pace
that I should talk to them uh should we
set up meetings every week should they
be every other week should they be three
times a week how long
you don't do any of that why not I
hate calendar I hate I hate one-on-one
meetings I think one of them meetings
how many of you do one-on-one meetings
everyone's going to tell you this is a
very contrarian approach so you do
one-on-one meetings because people tell
you that this is a time for you to catch
up with your employees and it's a time
where they can kind of come to you with
their concerns and blah blah blah blah
blah blah you know I was reading I was
reading about uh Jen San Juan
he has 45 direct reports he does no
one-on-one meetings this sounds like
Steve Jobs uh
one-on-one meeting Steve Jobs had 30
direct reports 30 direct reports yeah it
I mean it's not just a way for him to be
leveraged across more people it's also
just a way to cut out a bunch of you got
to collapse the stack that's a whole
other thing but this this point about
um no one-on-one meeting so one-on-one
meetings tend to clog up your calendar
so if you have 12 direct reports and you
have a one-on-one meeting with each of
them each week that's like 12 hours and
if you work you know 72 hours a week or
whatever that's 1 6th of your week which
has just gone away into literally
one-on-one meetings which is not
productive and also burned up their time
there's another part about this too
which is like it's not obvious to me
that you should be having private
conversations with people that the rest
of the team can't see or hear and so
like if you come up with a great idea
into the one-on-one or something
or you're working on something that
other people are tangentially related to
I just think it could be better to have
that conversation in a group setting and
so then you begin to think about okay
what are the kinds of conversations that
do need to be private and or private
one-on-one conversations and guess what
those tend to be things that you
shouldn't even be talking about in the
first place or just a waste of
time because it's just people
complaining it's just people thinking
about their own you know career
advancement which which is important but
doesn't need to be addressed every week
in a one-on-one setting and it tends to
turn into a therapy session which uh you
know
uh you you were probably not a licensed
therapist and therefore shouldn't be
doing this
when you have so many direct reports
you're not delegating anything
specifically young Founders I think are
told build a team trust your people do
all this
you go and you look at everyone from
Mark Zuckerberg all the way on down
today
these dudes are micromanaging yes to a
degree that would scare most people
why
every as your company grows the first
thing that of DC is going to tell you is
you need to figure out how to delegate
and then they're going to start to
introduce you to some people they're
like hey you should meet
Charlie Charlie
ran sales enablement at Salesforce
you know this person ran something at
Oracle and they really you know just
have a conversation they start to throw
these weird sort of people at you and
you're like what the is this like
what is sales enablement what is you
know all this stuff and then these
people come in and they show up and they
have they they're awesome and like in an
interview situation you start to talk to
these people and and they're they're so
good at talking about like all this
stuff that sounds great and then you're
like what the did they just say and
it's it's one of the the things that you
have to be like a buzzword a keyword
here which is like for me a big red flag
is when I hear the word Playbook like
well we come in and we run our Playbook
here their playbook is to actually hire
a bunch of people to run a Playbook that
also then do the exact same thing
recursively all the way down the chain
so
you know what I would recommend is to
delegate nothing
to do as much as you possibly can to
identify what you specifically are
awesome at like your superpower if
that's product then don't delegate
product if that's a particular part of
engineering don't do it if it's business
development you're doing deals don't
delegate that you can have some people
that help you do those things in support
of you but don't just like try to
replace yourself with someone that's
going to do that so then you can focus
on bigger picture items and scale and
stuff you may need to hire specialists
in other areas
um Finance is one in particular that as
you grow and if you want to get big and
run a public company you'll have to hire
a CFO specialist and they will have
their playbook and it will be
expensive and they'll be hiring all
kinds of people and Auditors and all
this kind of stuff that come in that's
all that's all par for the course but
when it comes to the unique thing that
makes your company special
look Mark Zuckerberg still wakes up
every day and I guarantee you the first
thing he does is check the threads stats
I guarantee it like he's looking at how
many threads were yesterday that's
that's like what he lives for and he
doesn't need to be doing that still uh
and that's just what a Founder ought to
be doing you just don't give up what is
core keep it as close as possible as
someone that worked on Facebook I
guarantee he's like
um Sunday night exec calls is something
that you do what are those calls what
are you guys talking about who's on them
and what are you doing
so I love to just kind of get the tnd
everyone how many of you work Sunday
nights
everybody everyone's working Sunday
nights uh so everyone's working Sunday
nights anyway and you kind of around 8
or 9 p.m you start to kind of come back
after your weekend or whatever and
answer the emails and start to catch up
why not just get everyone together for
an indefinite amount of time which could
go from one to four hours begin at 8 p.m
uh and sort of just get through all that
that way the whole the whole team is
ready to go you know 9 A.M Monday
morning so this is something I've been
doing for 15 17 years just a Sunday
night exact call we don't turn the
there's no cameras it's just it's a call
it's just a it's a way for everyone to
kind of get a line for the week I
actually read Tim Cook does this uh and
if you if you think about Apple it makes
complete sense because he's probably you
know talking to Asia which is already
the next day for them by by that point
and they're thinking about the supply
chains and they just it's a way to kind
of stay a step ahead so I I think a
Sunday night exec call almost saves your
team a half day a half day otherwise if
you do it Monday morning and it's a one
to four hour call then it's like nine to
you know noon that next morning you know
for for a full morning for the the
company and then it's like okay well we
just had the meeting and so now like you
know I'm in that sort of afternoon
energy and I'm not ready to like crush
the actual tasks if you do it the night
before you can wake up that this morning
and uh you know as as someone said today
is going to be amazing let's crush it
relentlessly
[Music]
um something that you taught me is
there's a difference between remote work
and distributed work yeah
and my thought process of it is that
there's in office everyone knows what
that is what is the difference between
remote work and distributed work well I
kind of think the whole remote work to
be it's kind of stupid
a hundred percent of successful
companies have people everywhere doesn't
matter if you're uh
an agency a tech company a doctor's a
hospital you just got your people
everywhere and the more
big you get the more places your people
are just gonna be there's going to be
specialists in Canada you're going to
have call centers in the Philippines
you're going to have engineering centers
potentially in different areas across
the country you might have reps in the
field you have your sales reps
everywhere the founder and CEO you're
all here in New York right now you you
know where should you be you should
probably be with customers if you're not
working on your product and so uh a
hundred percent of successful companies
are distributed the people are
everywhere and so for me when I was
running next we had offices from Berlin
to Beijing and I always just wanted to
kind of have in my pocket the whole
company in one headquarters from
anywhere and that's why I founded Rome
because I wanted to solve the problem of
being able to have everyone in One
office even when they couldn't
physically be together because when
you're all here when we're all in under
this one roof and if we're all in desks
and working and stuff we we have these
quick fast conversations and
you know as as we've moved to this sort
of Zoom calendar industrial complex
which I think Sam lesson called it uh
we've all now begun to block these 30
and 60 Minute Zoom calls for internal
stuff and that is why uh you know I
found in Rome to get out of having to
have that so you can just get back to
having these fast short conversations
everywhere so distributed work is really
I think the correct term there are
remote first companies I actually think
what matters more than where the company
is physically located is the Cadence by
which the work happens whether it's sync
or async I actually think that's the
bigger question that a Founder needs to
decide much more than are we remote or
hybrid or in the office what are the
pros and cons
sync and async oh I think async
sucks
uh no I I look there's there's async
work I I think there's some people that
try to run their company like a computer
program and there's a lost element of
humanity when you try to do that I think
you can definitely do that when you have
like a 35 person company I think by the
time you get to 100 people and then 150
is when you start to not know everyone's
name which is kind of weird for a
Founder like you right now if you're a
founder and you have 32 people in your
company like you are in total command of
everything you know every single detail
and you can sort of run it like it's a
big giant document and you can do it in
slack or Google Docs or whatever and you
don't have to have synchronous work I
think now I think humans by their very
nature of Being Human need to
feel a connection
need to feel a human connection and I
think that's part of the collective
unconscious it's part of life it's a
meaning of life to to be with people and
to win together and to uh by the way
that gets back to the co-founder comment
when you're a co-founder and you win
together it's like winning a battle
together which makes you feel closer to
people which is a cycle that repeats
itself and so when you're when you're
working on something hard and you're
looking out
and you're eating glass jumping off the
cliff into the darkness
when you know that other people are
doing that with you
it just makes it a little easier so
there's something about working with
people being present that at the same
time
that brings people and I believe creates
Better Business outcomes not because
like we're all collaborating on the idea
but even if you're doing deep work you
need to know that there's other people
around you doing deep work too
I don't know if we have a video that
we're going to play they'll play it if
uh yeah uh but while we're waiting for
that
um
Roma's this really unique thing where uh
whether you have multiple offices or
people are actually remote
um you almost replicate the
communication structure and a lot of the
different things that you would do
inside the office and
a water cooler talk I call it kind of
but it's actually a really
important function in the company
there's like a culture component to it
but there's also an exchange of
information uh there's ideas that come
from that yeah bring that into a virtual
environment is really hard right people
don't just like randomly send each
other's Zoom legs and like yeah you want
to jump in here and just like shoot the
and so talk a little bit as to like
the product design and how you all think
about shipping updates and really kind
of listening to customers well yeah so I
mean let me just quickly tell you a
little bit about Rome and what we're
doing so first
Zoom was the first company to really
solve the video conferencing technology
problem and if you remember video
conferencing before Zoom it was
absolutely terrible oh here we go cool
so uh
well here it is
um this is your Virtual Office this is
your whole company in one headquarters
so you can see everyone gets a shared
view of who's where
hi jump into different different kinds
of rooms uh obviously we have all this
stuff you'd expect like white boards and
uh but one of the cool things about Rome
is there's different types of rooms
that's a theater in the middle uh you
can give all hands presentations in the
theater the audio only rooms which are
private offices are the most popular
room format Believe It or Not 76 percent
of meetings in Rome are Audio Only the
average meeting time in Rome is just
eight minutes long can you repeat that
the average meeting time in Rome is just
eight minutes long why is that I think
it's because
going back to the zoom thing for a
second we've all moved to these 30 and
60 Minute meetings and so things that
used to take two people five minutes in
an office right now are being scheduled
for 30 and 60 Minute zooms next week but
if I need to just chat with pomp about
something right now and I see he's in
his office I can pop over and have that
quick fast conversation with him and
we're just done and not only do I save
him time because I didn't calendar him
but I also got the thing done faster
because it was able to happen like now
as opposed to waiting until I was able
to like free him up and he could
schedule something and whatever so we're
just back to kind of this fast
synchronous work and we've been you know
we clearly made this thing for ourselves
and we've been using it but the velocity
at which we were shipping is
extraordinary uh you know now if you
look just in the past couple quarters we
can really compete with slack on chat
we've got Integrations we can we got
something better than fireflies and
Otter so we can compete on summarization
in our in our group chat with our
feature called Magic minutes which
transcribes and summarize houses and
then creates a group chat with everyone
in it about our our uh about the call we
have a catch me up feature if you're
late to a meeting bam you'll get a
summary right there with like what like
what you missed um that nobody else sees
and you can prompt it you can say was
pomp mentioned you know like I did you
know in what context since Anthony said
yeah so but one of the pieces I think as
I've kind of seen people start to use
this product and folks have you know
shared feedback is that we talk a lot
about like shipping culture right and
shipping a lot of iteration of software
very very quickly what you all seem to
be doing is getting information to go
faster inside of an organization what is
the importance of that because you're
unique in that you're building a startup
right I don't know how many people Rome
has today but it's a lot less than
yextad but you went through the full
life cycle you've seen running the
public company right from start to
finish
um
and it almost feels like a lot of the
decisions you're making today are
specifically focused on not I'm trying
to run a 10 person company today right
it's I'm trying to set the foundation to
run a public company that's worth
billions of dollars and has you know
thousands of I'm trying to give every
one of you the foundation to run a
building to our public company
just like why is the information speed
so fast and such a big Focus you know
when you look at our own map when you're
in an office you get extraordinary
signal about what's going on so if you
walk into a physical office you can see
who's there you can see who's talking to
who you get a sense of people's moods
you can tell kind of the energy level
right away that is all gone when you're
on a zoom that's isolated in a silo it's
all gone when you're on slack and
everyone's just chatting all day but
when you look at their own map you can
immediately get sort of a Marauders map
for the office uh and you get a feeling
for who's there who's talking to who you
can knock on people's door it gives you
this kind of extra signal that you just
don't get uh in a sort of Zoom type Zoom
first Microsoft teams first world
um and you know we also talk to our
customers all day long so that's the
other thing like in in Rome you know we
go over we chat with them we'll pop over
we'll say hi uh and
you know and pomp we didn't talk about
this but I will say we're in closed beta
right now and we're going slow
uh I wasn't gonna break everyone's heart
that they can't sign up at the moment
you can join the waitlist there's a
thousand companies in the wait list and
we're going slow we have now 263 paying
customers we're getting close to about a
million dollars of ARR but that's not
our goal and I do have some advice for
all of you in this which is
don't let your VCS dictate a growth rate
now you might kick me for this because
you are probably an investor in all the
companies here and
um you do want to be able to say hey you
need to grow acts but I just think it's
sort of arbitrary it's like managing the
economy centrally to set the you know to
let a VC set the inflation number or
something like that like whoops whoops
the FED seems to not be working yeah
it's like the fed the VC is like the FED
basically setting what growth should be
a growth Target and like
when you work backwards to achieve a
growth rate say you know X percent based
on where you are all you're trying to
solve for is this like number that the
VC said that you have to grow at that
speed in order to X and you will end up
doing things that are unnatural that may
not be in the medium and long-term
interest of your business
um examples of that are over hiring
sales people or sdrs and pushing
companies too hard to try you too soon
before they're ready and uh and spending
a lot of money on acquisition that's
otherwise not worth it so I I would just
pretty much push back on any any sort of
sort of working backwards from a growth
rate you can only kind of do things
naturally it doesn't mean you don't make
smart Investments and Bets it just means
that building a company's a little bit
like building a garden and you just kind
of have to do it piece by piece over
time and it takes a long time and you
should build something that you want to
own forever and if it doesn't feel right
when you hire an SDR it's just gonna
spam the world about your brand and
potentially undermine you in the medium
and long run just to hit a growth Target
so that you can raise the next round
you're just playing a different game
than building a long-term lasting
company the last thing I want to talk
about is fundraising itself um
uh you're a successful founder whether
you like it or not and so you have an
advantage in some meetings in others you
may not and you've had a lot of
experience meeting with investors who
gave you money a lot of investors who
told you to kick rocks and get out of
their office some who have laughed at
you and some who love you because you
may have a lot of money in the IPO
when you went to a fundraise from Rome
what was the strategy and why well that
was
that was easy because when you've uh
yeah come on guys it's easy that was
easy well and I'm just being frank with
you like it was easy because when you've
made someone a lot of money before they
typically will will back you again so I
don't unless you've done that with
someone it's hard to kind of take that
as like your strategy like I pretty much
just called the person that I wanted to
do the deal with I said this is the deal
and then then and this is something you
can do and I do recommend doing and
everyone is doing this so it's not
particularly a novel idea but we do have
55 incredible uh Founders in the cap
table so use your cap table as a weapon
I think is maybe the advice there which
is you ought to be thinking about who
you can bring along this journey because
um
you know and I use the 55 people in the
cap table that are great Founders and
CEOs and well-known investors I'd like
kind of treat them like they work for
Rome you know and I give them
assignments I say you do this you do
this you do this hey can you give me an
intro here and I think you you will find
a lot of people that are willing to do
this and um you know there's there's
another thing you can do too which has
made people advisors but if they're
willing to if they're successful enough
you can get them to be an investor so I
recommend I recommend trying to build
your cap table with call it three dozen
people that are that are awesome and you
can do it later on too if you've started
and you haven't done that yet you can
certainly in the next round add a dozen
people to it
on this vein um racing around uh
especially when you've been a successful
founder you closed around the second
that word gets out that you closed
around a lot more people are interested
yeah
some people open an uncapped note some
people will say thanks so much for your
interest I'll get back to you at the
next round some people will ignore
everyone
um what is the strategy that you've seen
kind of work best I I think it really
just depends on your company and what
your needs are I don't think there's a
single Playbook answer here uh if you
need to have more Capital you can
certainly take it in if there's somebody
you freaking love let them in an
uncapped note if uh and if if you're set
I you just shouldn't spend a lot of time
fundraising most of your I really do
think people raise too much money they
focus on you know on what VCS think as
the ultimate end and that is really not
what you're trying to do because the
most successful companies are not too
concerned about VCS and investors they
it's an important but not end-all be-all
part of the game raise money from your
customers and everything will take care
of itself the most important metric in
your company by far nothing else matters
except net retention if you have very
high net retention that means you have
customers that love you and you know
what follows net retention is organic
growth because when people love you
guess what they do they tell their
friends and if you create word of mouth
and you have people coming to you that
have heard of you from a very happy
customer not only are you going to grow
through the net retention of the
existing logos because people love you
they're going to tell other people and
that's going to make your acquisition
costs go down if your acquisition cost
goes down guess what you can charge
lower prices and guess what when you
charge lower prices it makes people love
you more because you're delivering a
higher Roi to them so this whole thing
is like a cycle where if you have high
net retention you get lots of referrals
which in turn lowers your acquisition
costs which you can then pass on to
those customers that helped you in the
first place in the form of lower prices
win win win totally do that don't worry
about trying to grow at a billion
percent just to you know just to make
feces happy don't raise your prices to
grow keep people happy focus on that
retention
where can people go to sign up for the
wait list
uh where do they go to sign if you want
to check out Rome so
okay the waitlist is a little bit you
feel so much pain he wants everyone to
use it no it's not this wait list and it
eats them alive and I love watching them
suffer up here the waitlist is a little
fake it was there is a wait list there
is a wait list but I'm gonna just let
you in on a secret when you sign up for
the waitlist actually what you're doing
is you're booking a tour
and you're booking a group tour and this
is the cool part about this is one
little hack that I don't really know why
I'm saying this out loud but I will we
we found that
when we did one-on-one tours they're
cool but then we basically started
getting too many people coming to us and
we didn't have enough people to do the
tours we started doing these group tours
so when you go on a tour it's a little
bit like going on a college campus Tour
of Rome where it'll be with a bunch of
other people who you don't know and it
really just makes it fun so that's what
the wait list is you still are in line
but actually you you join the waitlist
by going on a group tour so I would
encourage you all to check it out and go
on one of our fun group tours it's like
going to Disney World except you can go
through the express lane and and
experience the office of tomorrow
ro.am
and we'll play a little Scavenger Hunt
game there's a gentleman named John who
I'm not going to point out so you all
have to find them
he told me beforehand that he will skip
everyone to the front of the line if you
find which Howard doesn't like but
whatever
um all right thank you so much I
appreciate it kick ass